[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم انهى هذا العام رئاسته لحركه
مجتمع السلم في الجزائر والتي استمرت
دورتين لمده عشره اعوام بدات في العام
2013 وانتهت في العام الحالي 2023 ولد
الدكتور عبد الرزاق مقري في تشرين الاول
عام 1960 في ولايه المسيله في الجزائر في
الحي الذي خرج منه محمد بوضياف احد الوجوه
التاريخيه للثوره الجزائريه في وجه
الاستعمار الفرنسي واحد مؤسسي جبهه
التحرير الوطني والذي اغتيل بعد اقل من
سته اشهر من تسلمه منصب رئيس الجمهوريه في
الجزائر كان جد مقري لامه مفتيا في مدينه
المسيله وتعلم مقري من والده الالتزام
الديني كما يقول ومن ثم فلم يكن غريبا ان
يلتحق بالحركه الاسلاميه في الرابعه عشر
من عمره التحق بالجامعه عامه 79 وبدا
دراسه الطب في جامعه سطيف وتعرف هناك على
الجماعات الاسلاميه دخل في عمق الحركه
الاسلاميه في الجامعه من بوابه الصراع مع
شيوعينا والحركه الامازيغيه انذاكر لم يكن
الطب موائما لتطلعات الشعب الاسلامي فاكمل
دراسه الماجستير في الشريعه والقانون في
كليه الشريعه في جامعه الجزائر ويعد حاليا
الدكتوراه في كليه العلوم الاسلاميه هناك
حول الازمه الماليه عام 2008 عبد
الرزاقماني جزائري بارز فهو عضو مؤسس
لحركه المجتمع الاسلامي عام 91 من القرن
الماضي والتي تطورت وتمحورت اسما ومضمونا
وصولا للعهد الحالي وقد رافق مؤسسها محفوظ
نحناح من البدايه حتى تولى هو رئاستها وهو
ايضا الامين العام لمنتدى كوالالمبور
للفكري والحضاره العالمي والذي ينشط في
البلدان الاسلاميه الرجل غزير الانتاج
والتاليف له من المؤلفات صدام الحضارات
الحكم الصالح واليه مكافحه الفساد الاسلام
والديمقراطيه والانتقال الدي مقراطي في
الجزائر وغيرها من الكتب استضيفه في
حلقتين اتعرف فيها في الاولى على مسيرته
ومنها مسيره ونشاه الحركه الاسلاميه في
الجزائر وصولا الى حاله الصدام والعشريه
الدمويه التي شهدتها البلاد في التسعينيات
من القرن الماضي عبد الرزاق مقري ضيف
المقابله هذا المساء فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله دكتور دكتور عبد الرزاق مقري
مرحبا سعيدين جدا
بوجودك السياسي والمثقف والمفكر والمعني
بسياسه في بلاده وبالسياسه في العالمين
العربي الاسلامي صحيح صحيح نحن اسعد
الحوار مع الشخصيه مثلك مثقفه وتتحدث مع
المفكرين وهي مفكره كذلك وانت تعرف كيف
يعني تستلهم الحديث وكيف تجعله نافعا بارك
الله فيك ولدت في ولايه سطيف في ولايه
سابقا كانت ولايه سطيف وكانك اطلعت على
الموضوع هي هي الان ولايه المسيله منذ
1974 صارت ولايه المسيله ولكن قبل ذلك
كانت تتبع السطيف
وسكانها من القبائل سكانها قبائل متعدده
يعني
اغلب قبيله
هي الشمال وقبيله اولاد نايل في الجنوب
وتتفرع الى بطون والى افخار كثيره اخرى في
هذه الاسره نشات الدكتور عبد الرزاق انا
نشات في اسره مقهى المقري
وهي نفس الاسره التي منها الذي هو مشهور
باسم المقر صاحب الطيب يعني لانه اصل كذلك
من مقهى وهي عائله من الاسر الاولى التي
سكنت المسيله يعني في مدينه المسيله وفيها
يعني فيها عدد كبير من المجاهدين فتره
التحريم يعني احنا احنا
نسكن في حي اسمه العرقوب هذا العرقوب كان
قلب قلب الثوره في الولايات المسيله في
ولايه المسيله يعني فيه خمسين شهيد تقريبا
والاسر كلها كانت منخرطه في الثوره
التحرير يعني انا شخصيا يعني كل اعمامي
كانوا من المجاهدين وكل اخواني مسجلين في
وزاره المجاهدين الان يعني فكانت يعني
وكذلك هي هو الحي الذي ولد فيه ونشا فيه
محمد بوضياف الرئيس الجزائري
الذي هو او يعني رئيس مجموعه 22 الذين
فجروا الثوره واول رئيس جبهه التحرير في
وقت
ماذا تركت الثوره في في عبد الرزاق الطفل
في تلك الفتره
والروح الوطنيه
مصالح البلد لانني انا اعرف عوائل الشهداء
مجاهدين كثر ونشات على حديث الثوره وعلى
اتحاد الحديث تضحيات سمعت يعني خاصه من
النساء من الوارده وجدتي كانت كذلك يعني
المجاهدين عن تلك الماسات وكيف كان
العسكري يهجم على البيوت وينزل من السقوف
كيف كانوا ياخذون يعني الرجال وبعض منهم
لا يرجع يرمى يعني خارج المدينه يعني في
الحقيقه نشات عندنا هذه الغيره على البلد
وهذه الروح الثوريه وعدم نقابه الظلم
والثوره ضد الظلم يعني بما ينفع مصلحه
البلد بشكل عام لكن الجبهه حموله ثقافيه
لاحقا
نفرق بين جبهه قبل الثوره وبعد الصلاه نحن
نتحدث عن جبل التحرير ما قبل التي افضت
الى تحرير صارت الحزب الواحد الذي حكم
البلد اكثر من 30 سنه وبعد التعدديه بقي
بطبيعه الحال هو جهاز من اجهزه السلطه نحن
اذا لا نتحدث على جبهه لم تكن اثر اعجاب
بالنسبه لك كشافه مقتبل العمر انا اتكلم
عن حموله السياسيه والثقافيه كحزب سياسي
حزب
اشعر وحزبي نشعر باننا قاربين لاننا عند
وعاء ثقافي واحد وطني واحد يعني خاصه
الجيل الاول الان الاجيال القياديه تغيرت
في الاحزاب كلها او كذلك في حزب جبهه
التحرير اما الجيل الاول انا يعني في
الحلقه استفدت منه كثيرا كان اكثر نفوذا
وتاثيرا على الشباب في تلك الفتره بسبب
تجربته وامكانياته الهائله
في الثمانينيات
وكذلك جزء من التسعينيات يعني كانت كانت
تاثير الدعاه اكثر يعني
تاثير تاثير في المجتمع اكثر بكثير ولكن
كان التعصير متبادل لان قاده جبهه التحرير
في ذلك الوقت كان ميولاته اسلاميه يعني
كانت لان الثوره التحريريه هي ثوره في
الحقيقه قامت على اساس اسلامي احنا لما
يعني نقرا الان في بيان اول نوفمبر بان
اول هدف للثوره هو بناء الدوله الجزائريه
الديمقراطيه الشعبيه الاجتماعيه سيده ضمن
اطار المبادئ الاسلاميه وكان المقاول مسمى
مجاهد
والمقتول يسمى شهيد في حموله دينيه واضح
حموله دينيه ماذا تغير بعد ذلك
اذ تغير في البدايه هي السياسه يعني في
البدايه يعني بعد الثوره يعني كان هناك
اجماع وطني عند الطبقه السياسيه كلها
بمضامين الثوره كالناس كلهم متاخرين
وبعدين يعني الحرص على السلطه والحرص على
النفوذ يعني هو الذي جعل الناس يتغير يعني
وهذا الشيء طبيعي السلطه السياسه لها
تاثيرها في الانسان في شخصيته في فكره في
موالاته في علاقته بالغير كذلك نشات
اسلاميه دكتور نعم اول في العائله ثم في
الحركه الاسلاميه العائله كلها نشاط كان
للاب لاحد من اطراف الاسره نشاطا اسلاميه
سياسيه لا في
الحاله التقنيه يعني
مواليد 1960 يعني لم يكن هناك صحوه
اسلاميه كما كان في اواخر 70 وثمانينيات
يعني الاسره كانت متدينه تقليديا يعني
وانا تعلمت الصلاه من والدي من الاسره
كذلك
جدي كان امام ومفتي الحي يعني معروف الشيخ
نذير الله يرحمه فلذلك
مثل الغير يعني من الكثير من
هذه الحاله من تدين العام الى الى الى
نشاط اكثر يعني تفصيلا وعند خراط في
الدعوه لان في البدايه كانت دعوه
يعني انا خربت يعني بالضبط في سنه 1974
كنت في سنه رابعه متوسط في الرابعه عشره
من عمره اي نعم في الرابع عشر من عمري
تعرفت على مؤسس العمل الاسلامي في ذلك
الوقت الشيخ محمد مخلوفي عن طريق شقيق
يعني وكنت في السنه الرابعه واذكر اليوم
بالذات يعني تفاصيل ذلك
لا اريد ان اعطي العنك لقص عليك هذه القصه
الطريفه التي اكررها وفعلا السابقين يعني
وبعدين طيله فتره الثانويه كنا يعني كان
عندنا نشاط كبير جدا في الثانويه لما
مشينا للجامعه نصرنا في موقع قيادي في اي
اي تيارات الاسلاميه كانت سائده في تلك
الفتره في في مدينتك المسلمين
نحن لم نكن نعرف يعني غير هذا يعني يعني
لما صعدنا الجامعه مثلا انا دخلت في
الجامعه في 78 99 لم اكن اعرف بان هناك
حركات اسلاميه لانها كانت سريه لم تكن
علانيه احنا كنا شباب يعني ولكن من كنا
نتنافس معهم يعني الحركات اليسريه
والحركات
الاخوان المسلمين والتضحياتهم وكفاحهم
وفضل العلماء يعني على الصحوه الاسلاميه
يعني يعني احنا في الجزائر بالذات يعني في
الثمانينات يعني كان الشيخ محمد الغزالي
كان له تاثير كبير جدا ليس في الشعب
الجزائري فقط بل حتى في المسؤولين فهو كان
صديقي جديد وبعده الشيخ القرضاوي جاء بعده
الجزائر اقام كذلك في الجزائر ولكن الشيخ
محمد الغزالي هو الذي اقام كثيرا فاذا
يعني في الثمانيات كانت الامور البسيطه
مثلا اصبحتم اخوانا بالمعنى التنظيمي
يعني في الجامعه في الجامعه لما تعرفنا
واحنا صرنا مسؤولين في الحركه الاسلاميه
يعني صار نعرف وكذلك ولكن العمل كان اغلبه
دعوي صحيح نحن انخرطنا في العمل السياسي
مبكرا يعني انا اذكر في 1976 يعني كنت
بجنب الطوابير التي
كانت موجوده لمناقشه ميثاق الوطني ميثاق
الوطني اللي كان هو الوعاء الاشتراكي الذي
كانت بطبيعه تعارضه الحركه الاسلاميه وكان
من سبقونا
يتحدثون وينقدون يعني
يجب ان نعترف بان النقاش حول الميثاق
الوطني كان في حريه كبيره جدا حريه في
الحديث في الحديث يعني ولك في اخر مره ليس
اكثر من ذلك بعد ذلك الميثاق يعني مر يعني
كما ارادوه له ولكن كانت فرصه
للتعبير تعبير التيار في الوقت عن موقفي
عن رعيه عن معارض فيه الاشتراكيه فكان
هناك نقاش ولكن جل العمل جل المناشط يعني
كانت يعني انا اريد ان افهم التيارات
الاسلاميه التي كانت سائده في الجزائر في
تلك الفتره الاخوان المسلمين كحركه اساسيه
ما هي الطيارات الاخرى هي الحقيقه يعني
قبل يعني قبل
قبل ما
تتضح معالم الجامعات الاسلاميه في منتصف
الثمانينات كانت التي تسمى بانها اخواني
المسلمين كانت حركات
بالطبعا كانت حركه عبد الله جبل الله شيخ
عبدالله كانت حركه التي عرفت باسم الشيخ
محمد سعيد وان كان ليس هو مؤسسها وليس هو
من القاده الاوائل فيها ولكن عرفت باسمه
فيما بعد يعني وكانت حركه الشيخ محفوظ
لحناح هذه كلها كانت تسمى ولكن الذي والذي
كان يتحدث باسم الاخوان المسلمين في بدايه
السبعينيات الى غايه نهايه السبعينات بشكل
واضح هو الشيخ عبد الله جاب الله في
الحلقه لان المعبر الرسمية كان معبر بشكل
واضح بانه اخوه المسلمين الشيخ محفوظ كان
في السجن الشيخ محمود دخل في السجن يعني
من 75 الى غايه 81 دكتور هذا ثمه تباين في
المسارات الثلاث في العناوين الثلاث داخل
الاخوان المسلمين فيه تباينات يعني كليه
وفيه تبني الجزئيه لو لما نتحدث نحن عن
الاخوان المسلمين كتيار فيه ثلاث جماعات
كانت توصف بان اخوه المسلمين اللي هي
جماعه الشيخ عبد الله جاب الله التي في
الحقيقه هي اول من ظهر باسم الاخوه
المسلمين على نيه في الجامعات طيله يعني
نهايه السبعينيات وبدايه الثمانينيات يعني
وهناك جماعه التي بالرغم من انها في
الحقيقه لا تقبل ان تسمى المسلمين وكان
بينهم وبين الاخوان المسلمين يعني كثير من
الخلافات ولكن تسمى في الاطار العام
والمسلمين وهناك جماعه الشيخ محفوظ معناه
الشيخ محفوظ نحن لم يظهر باسم اخوه
المسلمين في منتصف السبعينيات لانه كان في
السجن فلذلك لم يكن يعبر عن ذاته بالرغم
من صلته قبل ذلك فلما خرج الشيخ محفوظ
نحناح من السجن كانت هناك محاولات لاتفاق
بينه وبين عبد الله باعتبار انهم يعني
ينتمون الى تيار واحد لم يحصل ذلك فالذي
اشتهر اكثر في نهايه الثمانينات باسم
اخوان المسلمين هو الشيخ محمود رحمه ما
الذي كان اكثر ارتباطا بالجماعه الام
بتنظمين العالم يخلينا والله في البدايه
كان الشيخ محفوظ نحناح في السجن عمليا لا
اتحدث عن الامتدادات يعني التنظيميه التي
لا يعرفها الناس عمليا الذي كان اكثر
ارتباطا هو الشيخ عبد الله في نهايه سبعه
لما خرج الشيخ محمود السجن بالطاقه صار هو
يعني الاكثر يعني
الاكثر تعريفا بانه
ولكن بالاضافه الى التيار كان هناك
جمع دفع التي كان لها دور كبير
يعني وانا شخصيا يعني في بدايات حياتي في
شبابي مشيت مع جماعه
السلفيه لم تكن موجوده في الحقيقه يعني في
نهايه السبعينيات حتى بدايه الثمانينات لم
تكن معروفه في كانت هناك بعض الاسماء يعني
بعض منها في العاصمه مثلا الشيخ علي بالحج
كان يوصف بانه الاخوان المسلمين في بدايته
كان كذلك بعض الاسماء في سطيف في الغرب
الجزائري ولكن لم تكن
جماعه او حركه اساسيه يعني قويه يعني ظهرت
فيما بعد يعني تقوت يعني اكثر من ذلك
بالاضافه الى الحركه الصوفيه التقليديه
المعروف ان الحركات في الجزائر لها تاريخ
عريق فالحقيقه هي اول من تصدى الاستعمار
يعني لما تخلص الاستعمار في 1830 كل
الحركات الجهاديه التي قاومت الاستعمار
كانت صوفيا الامير عبد القادر
كان كذلك في ازعاج كان
في الغرب الجزائري الشيخ السياسيه
في فطرتكم لم يعني لم لم تتمظهر بالمظهر
السياسي ولكن هناك بعض الشخصياتهم الذين
تمون الاحزاب هم اقرب لاحزاب السلطه هم
اقرب اكثر الاحزاب السلطه بشكل عام يعني
ولكن له موجود يعني ولم تاثير في الحقيقه
يعني تاثير تحفيظ القران الكريم وغير ذلك
يعني بالطبع في بداياتهم فصور التحريريه
كانت الحركه المقاومه
اتحدث عن مقاومه الشعبيه يعني نقول من
1830 الى
بدايه القرن العشرين يعني الى 19 والى
غايه
192015 بدات تضعف يعني فكانت حركات جيه
بعدها بعض الحركه الصوفيه صارت تشتغل مع
الاستعمار وبعضها بقي يعني في الحركه
الوطنيه بشكل عام يعني فهذه هي بشكل عام
يه لها حضور مميز وخاصيه موجوده في منطقه
في في الجزائر في جنوب الجزائر اللي هي
غردايه لها تنظيمها الخاص ولها يعني
اسسيه الخاصه لها شبكاتها يعني خاصه سوف
التعليم وفي التجاره يعني والجميع يعني
مسلم بخصوصيتها حتى السلطات مسلمه
بخصوصيات حتى في وقت الاستعمار كان هناك
خصوصيتها وهي في الحقيقه
هي تمزج بين الخصوصيه المذهبيه والخصوصيه
العرقيه كذلك لانهم هم امازيغ يعني ولكن
اجتمعت الخصوصيه على ادى الى عزلها عن عن
باقي النسيج الوطني بشكل لا نستطيع ان
نقول بان معزول عن عن نسيج الوطني لانهم
مواطنين مندمجين يعني في البلد في السياسه
في المجتمع في الحراك هم في السياسه عموما
يترشحون في قوائم مستقله على العموم
مستقله ويترشحون في احزاب السلطه يعني
نادرا وقع حدث هذا ان فيهم من ترشح يعني
في احزاب من احزاب غير السلطه ولكن على
العموم يعني في الحاله العام يعني انه
يترشحون في جبهه التحرير الوطني او التجمع
الوطني الديمقراطي ولكن الحضور فعلي وعن
طريق القوائم مستقله وهم في الحقيقه يعني
هو مجتمع متدين مجتمع محافظ
بالطبع اكيد صارت مشاكل في الفتره الاخيره
يعني عرقيه في غردايه نرجو ان شاء الله ان
تنتهي وترجع الامور الاستقرار ما العنوان
الرئيسي الذي كان سائدا لديكم ابناء حركه
اسلاميه في نهايه السبعينات
العناوين الرئيسيه في الدوله
الاشتراكي اتجاه اشتراكي كا اتجاه علماني
في وجهه نظرنا وكاتجاه اقتصادي نعتبره
بانه ظالم وغير نافع للبلد يعني بالطبع
هذه الاطروحات ظهرت بانها هي الصحيحه يعني
الشيخ محفوظ نحناح رحمه الله
وعارض الثوره الزراعيه دخل السجن من اجل
هذا ولكن بعد ذلك الدوله كلها تخلت على
هذا على هذا النهج وسلكه طريقا اخر يعني
فاذا الموقف كان على اساس فكري على اساسي
اتوقف عند هذه النقطه خرجنا تخرجنا من
الجامعه وبدات سنوات في غايه الاهميه سواء
على الصعيد الشخصي او على الصعيد السياسي
في الجزائر وعلى صعيد ايضا الحركه
الاسلاميه بشكل عام نستانف الحوار على
طاوله الحوار سعيدين شكرا اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]
ربيع جزائري مبكر ذلك ما مثله انتفاضه
اكتوبر من عام
1988 في الجزائر وقتها ضاق الشباب درعا
بحزب جبهه التحرير الحاكم الحزب الواحد
الذي استولى على السلطه واستاثر بها القى
ذلك بضل عليه على المشهد السياسي فجر في
العام التالي تغيير الدستور الذي سمح
بتعدديه سياسيه وحزبيه في الجزائر لاول
مره منذ استقلال البلاد عن المحتل الفرنسي
اسفر اقرار الدستور عن عشرات الاحزاب لكن
اكثرها بروزا كان حزب الجبهه الاسلاميه
للانقاذ الذي حظي بموافقه رسميه على
تاسيسه في سبتمبر من العام نفسه بزعامه
عباس مدني وعلي بلحاج في يوليو من عام
1990 اجريت الانتخابات البلديه ليحقق
التيار الاسلامي فوزا كبيرا وجاء ذلك
متزامنا مع تصاعد وتيره عنف قادتها قوات
الامن تجاه الاسلاميين وعلى الرغم من
تاجيل الانتخابات التشريعيه الاستحقاق
الانتخابي الاهم لسته اشهر وفرض الاحكام
العرفيه واعتقال بالحاج مدني فقد عقدت
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات اواخر ديسمبر
من عام 91
حدث المتوقع وفازت جبهه الانقاذ ب 188
مقعدا بينما لم يفز حزب جبهه التحرير
باكثر من 16 مقعدا لتشكل هذه النتيجه
صاعقه للرئيس انذاك الشاذلي بنجديد وحزب
السلطه فضلا عن الجيش والمؤسسات الامنيه
التي كانت على راس الرافضين للتيار
الاسلامي منذ بداياته
عجلت النتائج بانقلاب عسكري قاده وزير
الدفاع خالد نزار ومجلسه السري رفضا
لاستلام جبهه الانقاذ الاسلاميه مقاليد
الحكم بل ونعت بيان الانقلاب الجبهه
بالحزب التكفيري والمتطرف لم يقبل
الاسلاميون بهذا القرار الهادف الى واد
تجربتهم الوليد فانتفضوا في الجزائر طولا
وعرضه لتدخل البلاد في دوامه عنف استمرت
عشره اعوام اسقطت ما يقدر بنحو 200 الف
قتيل عدا عن عشرات الالاف من الجرحى
فتره الثمانينات عناوينها الرئيسيه كانت
الصراع ايضا باتجاه الديمقراطيه التي
انتهت ب88
قبل خمسه اكتوبر ثمانيه حدث
ما يجعل
الانتفاضات الشعبيه تحدث وهي مساله
سونانيه لا تتغير ولا تتبدل اجتمع
الاستبداد مع الضعف الاقتصادي كان هناك
حزب واحد مستبد وقع فساد كبير جدا اصبحت
هناك فروق اجتماعيه كبيره جدا وانهارت
اسعار البترول في
تالي اثر الاستبداد والفساد اصبح اكثر
تاثير فكانت النتيجه احداث خمسه اكتوبر
ثمانيه خارج الناس الشارع ضد من خرجوا
يعني هي كانت فيه تلقائيه كبيره الى حد
الان السؤال يطرح الى حد الان من كان وراء
خمسه اكتوبر لا يزال الناس يطرحون السؤال
الى الان يعني ولكن بحكم ان الحركه
الاسلاميه كانت هي الاقوى في الشارع وهي
الاكثر تاثيرا فهي هي التي كانت الابرز هي
الحركه كانت حركه شعبيه في حق الناس
عاديين مواطنين عاديين كانت هناك حاله
اعتقال كبير
كبيره جدا يعني كانت هناك اراده للتغيير
ولكن باعتبار الحركه الاسلاميه كانت
موجوده فاستطعت ان تحتضن كانت في راس
المعارضه
هو الذي اخذ خيط الشارع اخذ الخيط من
الشارع
اللي هو الشيخ عباس المدني
الذين كان حضورهم ابرز من غيرهم في خمسه
اكتوبر اين كنتم انتم
السيارات الاخرى
مع الناس يعني ولكن الحركه الاسلاميه
المنظمه
لم تشاء ان تقود هذا الحراك يعني كانت
موجوده وكانت تستطيع ان تقود لو ارادت
يعني ولكن الشيخ العباسي مدني
لم يكن لهما تنظيم لم تكن لهما يعني خسائر
يمكنها فالحركه كانت اسهل يعني فاذا هم
التقطوا الخيط من الشارع يعني لان بعد
اكتوبر 88 89 تغير الدستور واصبح يسمح
بتاسيس
بدون اي بدون ماذا تاسسه من ايقاف يعني في
الحقائق نحن نتحدث على الشيخ عباس الله
يرحمه برحمته الواسعه الشيخ علي الحاج ومن
كان معهما او اغلب من كان معهما يعني لم
يكن لهما تنظيم تحدثت حديثا هاما عن
الجبهه وتكوينها وتعدديتها الواسعه اريد
ان افهم منك واريد ان يستمع له ايضا
المشاهد العربي الجبهه عباره عن ماذا جبل
صحيح الجبهه الاسلاميه لانقاذ هي فيها
التنوع كبير جدا
بالطبع اساسها راسها وعباس المدني
العباسي المدني كان شخصيه مستقله وهو كان
في جبهه الوطني وكان منتخب محليا في جبل
التحرير الوطني ولكن هم كان يمثل الجناح
المتدين الجناح المحافظ داخل هنا نصفه
بانه متدين ضمن جبهات التحرير وليس
اسلاميا حركيا يعني اثناء وجوده الاسلام
الحركيين ولكن بعد الرجوع من بريطانيا
اصبح يتحرك في الحركه الشاميه المنظمه
التي شرحناها في مقدمه هذا البرنامج واصبح
له قبول واصبح له قبول لانه كان جريئا
وكان مثقفا
ويتحدث بطريقه جديده بطريقه فكريه ويتحدث
عن
مركز
هو لديه شعبيه وشرعيه في جبهه التحرير
كاحد اعضاءها سابقا هو كان داخل جبل
التحرير يعني شخص عادي تقريبا ولكن في
المجتمع لما اصبح ضمن التيار الاسلام يعني
تقبله التيار الاسلامي لكن لديه يقصد جذور
ساعدت ايضا على جماهيره
وكان يعني بالحاجه يعني له جذور سلفيه
يعني هو من الاسماء الاولى التي برزت بهذا
الوصف السلفي وهناك مكون اخر وهو الحركات
الاسلاميه التي تنتمي للتيار اخواني بشكل
عام منها من كانوا مع الشيخ عبد الله جبل
يعني هناك شخصيات اساسيه في جبهه الاقامه
كانت مع الشيخ عبد الله يعني من بينهم ومن
ابرزهم عبد القادر الحشاني رحمه الله كان
من قيادات اللي كانت مع الشيخ عبد الله
علي بن الحاج رحمه الله
بلحاج يعني جدي رحمه الله
يعني
اخوانيه كانوا مع الشيخ عبد الله
وكانت هناك جماعه الجزائر التي دخلت
تقريبا بكل زخمها القيادي وكان فيه كذلك
يعني
الافاق العمل المسلح
الذي تاسس في
1985 يعني
بظهر طيار يعني مسلح ودخل في مواجهه مع
السلطه من هو وما هو تحديدا يعني هو في
الحقيقه
الشخص البارز فيهم اسمه بوعلي بوعلي هذا
هو الشخص البارز ولكن في شخصيات اخرى
ثم انخرط في العمل الدعوي
بصفه اسلام بصفه سياسيه اكثر يعني ثم احمل
السلاح طيب هؤلاء الذين هناك تيار اخر هم
التيار اخر هم الناس كانوا في السلطه يعني
الذين كانوا بخلفيه جبهه التحرير خرجوا
لاسباب لها علاقه بتدينهم بنظراتهم
الاسلاميه ام لاسباب ايضا يعني تتعلق
بامتعاظهم من اداء الحزب الحاكم واداء
السلطه بشكل عام ولكن داخل جبل التحرير
كان هناك صراع للديولوجي كبير وعميق جدا
جدا بين التيار الوطني الذي هو كان يعني
وراء قانون الاسره الذي كان التعريب الذي
كان وراء المنظومه التربويه التي كانت في
الحقيقه فيها بعد اسلامي كبير جدا وبين
تيار العلماني الذي نسميه نحن حزب فرنسا
حزب فرنسا داخل جبل التحريم اللي كانوا
موجودين يعني في الداخل المؤسس العسكريه
يعني وجودهم اكثر داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
كان هناك صراعات في بعض الاحيان يحدث
تشابك بينهما
على هويه الدوله الهويه مباشره
على قضيه التعريب يعني بشكل كبير انا احكي
لي
سي عبد القادر حجار الله يرحمه كان رموز
جبه التحرير يعني وكان هو رئيس السجن
التعريب في لحظه من اللحظات لما تم انهاء
ملف التعريب النسب يعني جماعه حزب فرنسا
بالبدلات العسكريه يعني حتى حتى
اشتباك يعني فاذا كان هناك صراعه ولكن
الصحوه الاسلاميه في الثمانينات
طبعا هنا لدينا دكتور الجبهه الاسلاميه
للنقاذ انتم كتجمعات لها علاقه بالاخوان
المسلمين المسارات الثلاث كان حضورها كيف
كان حضورها في هذه الفتره 88 الى 89
بالاحتجاجات وصولا الى تغيير الدستور لشوف
هو حتى لا يكون الخطاب مشتسعا كان
الصراع موجود كذلك يعني بين التيار
اشتراكي التيارات ابو مدين بعدين التيار
الذي كان مع شادي بن شديد وبقيه
كان هناك صراع سياسي اخر بالنسبه للحركه
الاسلاميه بطبيعه الحال بعد خمسه اكتوبر
88 89 تغير الدستور صار يسمح بتاسيس
الاحزاب فتاسيس الاسلاميه بكل هذه
المكونات بس انتم ما احنا لم يؤس كل كل
الحركات الثلاثه هذه كلها لانها في الحلقه
لم تكن تثق في هذه المبادره مبادره السلطه
كانت تعتبر بالطبع
الهاجس الامني عند الحركات الاسلاميه كانت
كبيره ولكن علي بن الحاج وعباسي المدني
في اخر المطاف هما اسوا حزب واخذوا
المبادره لما اخذوا المبادره تيار الشعبي
الكبير المتاثر بالحركه الاسلاميه بكل
مكوناتها كان لا يفرق بين الدعاه لا يعلم
بان فيها تنظيمات مختلفه يعني كان يرى
الصوره العامه
الدعوه الاسلاميه بشكل عام فاعتقدوا بان
الجبل
لم يكنوا بان هذه مثل جهه يعني فلذلك
الوعاء الاول الذي احترنا الجبهه
الاسلاميه
من كل التيارات
ثم بعد ذلك لان خطاب جبل السمينه كان
خطابا متشددا ضد النظام السياسي كل
الطبقات الشعبيه التي كانت معترضه عن نظام
السياسي او كانت متضرره انظر وتحقيق
اذا طبقه ثانيه واسعه جدا جدا ثم تكونت
طبقه ثالثه اخرى وهم كل بالسلطه حتى ممن
كانوا داخل السلطه التحقوا بالجبل لفهمها
وهذا ما سنبحثه هذا الامر كان نقطه قوه
وكان نقطه ضعف ايضا نعم هذا الذي
يتحدثون نقطه ضعف نقطه قوه لانه اعطى زخما
شعبيا كبيرا يعني معناه المعبر عن مجتمع
الجزائري عن مجتمع او قطاع وكل وكل مكون
من مكونات الجبهه له حاضنته الاجتماعيه
اذا صار هناك يعني طبقه شعبيه كبيره ولكن
نقطه ضعف ان هذا التنوع لا يسمح بوحده
القرار لا يسمح يعني لا يوجد واحد تصور لا
يوجد حتى بمركزيه
عباس المدني علي بلحاج سطوتهم جماهريتهم
لم يكن الامر سهلا في فرض داخل الجبهه لم
يكن بدليل ان الانشقاق الاول كان وقع يعني
قبل قبل
الانتخابات يعني معروف يعني كان هناك تنوع
كبير جدا وفي وقت الازمه يشتد الامر يصبح
الاتفاق على راي في وقت ما يستحيل يعني
بعد الغاء
الانتخابات في الحق صارت الحجه عند جماعه
مسلحه اكثر من السياسيين واكثر من
الجماعات المسلحه ودائما الجهات المتطرفه
تقول انتم تراهنون على المشاركه على
الانفتاح نحن نراهن ان هؤلاء لا يريدون
شيء والزمن بالنسبه اليهم اعطاهم الحق
بالنسبه لهم فلذلك فلذلك اصبح طيب هذا
التيار ضعفها ضائع التيار القيادي المدني
السلمي ضعفه بشكل كبير من بعد حدوث الازمه
بعد الانتخابات يقول تاكيد وكل ما مشى
الزمن وتعمقت الازمه الامنيه صار ضعيفا
الغريبه لما حدث الصدام انتم كحركات
اسلاميا حستوا لصالح النظام شوف احنا في
الحقيقه نحن كنا ضد الغاء الانتخابات موقف
لك واضحين ولكن نحن كنا غير موافقين على
منهج الجبهه الاسلامي نحن كنا نعتبر بان
هذا المنهج لا يحقق الاهداف المرجوه وان
هذا المنهج سيضيع الفرصه سيدخل اول البلد
يعني في ازمه وسيضيع الفرصه على المشروع
الاسلامي واحنا كنا في حوار كان حوار في
ذلك الوقت سري انا شخصيا دخلت في حوار مع
عبد القادر حشاني مع فريق من من حركه
مجتمع السلم بموافقه الشيخ محفوظ ربي
يرحمه في ذلك الوقت يعني انا شخصيا يعني
في خمس جولات حوار مع عبد القادر حشاني في
هذا الموضوع هذا وانا كاتب تفاصيل ما حدث
يعني كلمه كلمه موجود لم انشره الى حد
الان ولكن سانشره يعني
وحاولنا ان ننبه يعني
ضربه كبيره جدا وان هذا وان هذا الخط هذا
سيضعنا جميعا في معزق لستم انتم فقط بل
نحن جميعا اول مشروع الاسلامي اولا ثم
المجتمع الجزائري هنا بدات العشريه
السوداء
هنا بدات العشريه يعني بدا نحن في خضم
العشريه السوداء التي شهدتها الجزائر
هذا المعطى الاول ان هناك ايام سوداء
قادمه وهناك عمل قاسي وعنيف ضد الجميع
ايضا ماذا كان بالطبع للاسف هو مقتل عبد
القادر الحشاني كان في الحقيقه لصالح
الازمه وليس لصالح الحل لان عبد القادر
رجل عاقل كان بامكانه ان يساهم في حل
المشكله واحنا سمعنا منه كلام جيد يعني
فلما اشتدت الازمه بالطبع كل الطبقه
القياديه دخلت للسجن ولكن كانت هناك فرص
يعني لم تشتغل للاسف الشديد كنتوا تقابلون
للسلطه اكيد نحن كنا في حوار دعم شوف احنا
بدات الازمه
كنا دائما نطلق المبادرات انا عندي كتاب
فيه اكثر من 300 صفحه عنوانه مبادره لحل
الازمات ذكر فيها كل المبادرات من 1989
الى غايه 2019
فاحنا بعد بعد الغاء الانتخابات الدخول في
الازمه اطلقنا عده مباراه مبادره مجموعه
السبعه زائد واحد مبادره الصلح الوطني
مبادره السلام وكنا نريد ان نجمع بين
السلطه وبين المعارضه ولكن لا نفلح ذهبت
للسلطه مع من جلست معه كانت فيه فرصه
للحوار يعني
ماذا ما هو ما هو تقدير السلطه في وقت في
وقت في الحقيقه كان هناك طرح مقبول وانا
شاهد عليه يعني امام الله شاهد عليه يعني
كان حوار كان حاضر الشيخ الاستاذ
مهرير الشيخ محمود
العديد من الشخصيات يعني كان المشروع الذي
طرحه انا مستعد مستعد ان اطلق سراح جميع
السجناء وان
نسمح للجبهه الاسلاميه القاب بتاسيس حزب
ولكن عندي شرطين ان يتبراوا من الارهاب
بشكل واضح وان يغيروا الاسم
فاحنا مشينا
عفوا تغيير اسم تغيير الاسم يعني في ذلك
الوقت السلطه اطلقت بعض القاده من اجل
الحوار فاحنا زرنا الشيخ علي جدي والشيخ
بوخم الله يرحمه
فطرحنا عليهم الامر قلنا الفرصه وفي ذلك
الوقت
الاشتراكيه قلنا لهم اكبر مستفيد من عدم
رجوعكم للساحه السياسيه يجب التحرير وجبه
القوى الاشتراكيه لانكم منافس كبير له
واحنا لو لو لم نكن نريد الخير للبذل
الخير لكم لا مدعو لكم لقبول
من غيابهم مستفيدين احنا دع وناهم للرجوع
لو كانت لو كان لو كان طرحنا اناني حزبي
يعني
لا ما نحن كنا نت
حدث
هما هما
ترددوا في اخر المطاف يعني ما قبلوش هاد
الامر لا ادري التفاصيل بعد ذلك ماذا حدث
هل كانوا يستطيعون هذا فعل ذلك برايك
والله لا ادري اعتقد
انا في رايي كان عندهم تردد ولا يكون
عندهم وضوح الرؤيه وربما كانوا ينتظرون
ماذا ستفرزه الساحه يعني كيف ستكون الامور
يعني ربما بعض منهم بعض لا اريد ان اتهم
بالجمله بعض ممكن يعتقد انه قد يستفيد من
مما يحدث
شعبيا يعني كان يذكر او ينقل انه حتى
الشعب الجزائري كان كان سعيدا بنزول يعني
الدبابات الدوله الجيش لحمايته
انقلب الامر ضد الجبهه الاسلاميه للانقاذ
بالتالي الم يستشعروا المساله حتى من
الناحيه الشعبيه والحقيقه لما يعني
استحكمت الازمه وصارت الدماء
يعني صار الناس لما يرون الدبابه في
الشارع يشعرون بالاطمئنان فيه كلمه مشهوره
للاستاذ عبد الحميد المهري يا كلمه فلسفيه
تتجاوز البعد السياسي يقول لما يصبح
المواطن يشعر بالاطمئنان لما يرى الدبابه
معنى ذلك ان ازمه عمي قه جدا جدا ونحن حق
نحن كمواطنين عاديين والله كساسه لما نكون
في الطريق ونشوف
الحاجز يعني تاع الدرك الوطني نشعر
بالاطمئنان يعني نخشى ان يكون
هناك راي اخر يرى في ان هذه الدبابه وجدت
لقمعه ولمواجهته ضد خياراته وانها نتيجه
لموقف السلطه يعني ضد خيارات شعبيه
وديمقراطيه يعني معروف في التاريخ السياسي
يعني بان الاستبداد يستفيد من الازمات
معروف يعني في فيه
جنرال في الجيش الروماني معروف انه حينما
انقلب على
على مالكه يعني قبل ان يتحكموا ويكونوا في
مكانه يعني ترك المدينه في فوضى عارمه
فوضى كبيره جدا
وبعد ذلك دخل هو على على
رمزا كبير لو نجحت تحول السياسي الذي وقع
في خمس اكتوبر بدون عنف وبدون صدام وبدون
ربما كانت الجزائر يوم واحد من واحات
الديمقراطيه في البلاد العربيه ولربما راي
الان في مستوى ماليزيا ولا اندونيسيا ولا
تركيا يعني يعني
الفرصه التي ضاعت كبيره جدا والجرح عميق
ولا يمكن للانسان وطني انسان يفهم يفهم
كيف تتحول الازمات وكيف
تتغذى من بعضها البعض وكيف تفوت الفرصه
على الحريه وعلى الديمقراطي وعلى التنميه
لا يمكن لشخص يفهم هذا ان لا يتالم الذي
وقع في الجزائر شيء مؤلم لان سالت فيه
دماء ضاعت فيه يعني حقوق ولانها اغلقت
الافق على الجزائريه الازمه عميقه جدا هذه
امه الفرص الضائعه
كبيره لذلك انشاتم الحركه بشكل رسمي
انشانا الحركه قبل ما تبدا الدماء بطبيعه
الحال في ماء 1991 يعني بعد ما شفنا
الخطاب الذي انتهجته الجبهه الاسلاميه قال
يعني
راينا بان فيه ارهاصات بان ستكون ازمه
ونحن يجب ان نؤسس هذا الحزب لانقاذ ما
يكون انقاظه على الخطاب الناس احرار في
خطابهم الناس احرار في
السؤال ولكن احنا اسسنا الحز ب لنعطي راي
اخر لنكون لنكون كذلك
لنكون كذلك
في حلقه نجاه يعني
ايضا هذا الخيار الذي اعتمدت 91 وشاركته
بالسلطه 95 وفي البرلمان ووجودكم جزئي لم
يفضي الى شيء اليوم في حنا 2022 او 23
ايضا مثاليا هو خيار البقاء جيد
لصالح البلد يعني
سواء كنا اخترنا هذه الطريق او لم نختره
لكن في هذا الوضع او لا كنا في وضع اسوا
منه ولكن دخولنا نحن ابقى وجود فكرنا
وبدانا واقتراحاتنا
ومناضلينا وحاضمتنا الاجتماعيه والامل
يعني بقيه موجود دكتور مقدمه لحوارنا في
الجزء الثاني حول خيارات الاسلاميه انا
اردت ان اطرح هذه الاشكاليه مقدمه لاحياء
حوار معمق حوله خيارات الاسلاميين اليوم
انشاتم الحركه وشاركتم في السلطه واستمر
هذا الامر كنت نائما لرئيس الحركات ثم
اصبحت رئيسا لها في 2013
انا عضو مؤسس للحركه في91 لان هناك 18 شخص
يعني هم الذين اودعت اسمائهم لتاسيس الحزب
مع الشيخ ثم نائب رئيس في عهد الشيخ مجره
لعهدتين ثم صرت رئيس الحركه لعهدتين كويس
عندكم ديمقراطيه دكتور
بان
المسؤول يبقى عهدتين يعني انا من من اسس
لهذا الامر هذا يعني في عهدتك الاولى 2013
اخترت الاتجاه نحو المعارضه بشكل واضح
يعني الوقت ياخذنا كتير يعني قصه طريفه
فاحكيلنا القصه ظريفه انا في الحقيقه
كنت معارض لبقائنا في الحكومه منذ 1997
الى 2000 وانتم مجلسين الى 2012 موجودين
في الحكومه موجودين في الحكومه
لما تاسس لما النظام السياسي اسس التجمع
الوطني الديمقراطي وزور له الانتخابات
انا عرفت بان لا يوجد حل مع النظام
السياسي بهذه الطريقه الحديث يطول يعني
ربما في الخيارات سنه نعود الى هذا
الموضوع ولكن اشتدت معارضه الوجود في
الحكومه في 1999 من منع الشيخ محمود نحناح
من المشاركه في الانتخابات بعد وفاه الشيخ
في الحقيقه تعمق الاقتراب من السلطه تعمق
اكثر انا كنت عضو في المكتب الوطني نائب
رئيس شعرت بانه لم يصبح عندي
دور فقررت بان اغادر هياكل الحركه في
[موسيقى]
فكتبت رؤيه مستقبليه في الثلاثين صفحه
قريه تاع المكتب التنفيذي الوطني استشرفت
ماذا سيحدث وقررت بان بعد ثلاثه اشهر
سيكون المؤتمر وساغادر هيك الحركه الذي
حدث بعد ايام اسابيع قليل حدث الربيع
العربي
لما حدث الرابعه العربي تحول وقع التحول
عميق في قناعات المناضلين في القواعد راوا
بانهم في الجهه الخاطئه في وجود وفي
الحكومه يعني بالطبع اغلب اطارات حركه ذلك
الوقت كانوا متمسكين
النبوهه الثانيه صحيح يعني هذا في
التسعينات لما سيجري نحن بالطبع يعني بحكم
معرفتنا بالبلد وخبره والتجربه وغير ذلك
ففي الحقيقه بعدين صارت ضغط من القواعد
كبير بانه يجب ان نخرج من الحكومه
فخرجنا من الحكومه في 2012
سنه قبل 2016 واكتسب موقعك اهميه اكبر
رجعنا للمؤتمر في 2016 قد خرجنا من
الحكومه سنه قبل المؤتمر توجه المؤتمر لمن
يمثل هذا البديل الجديد
كبير جدا لبناء رؤيه سياسيه جديده لبناء
توجه ماذا استفدتم من خروجكم الحكومه مرات
احيانا انت وفق النظريه اللي اختلفتم فيها
مع الجبل الاسلاميه القائد الوجود والحفاظ
على المساحات المتاحه امر جيد انت الان
تترك هذه المساحه المتاحه شوف في الحقيقه
وجودنا يعني في الحكومه ساهم في بعض
القضايا الاستراتيجيه من بينها بطبيعه
الحال انه
ساهم في الاستقرار في البلد هذا شي اساسي
بالطبع لما يكون البلد يحترق انت لا تبحث
عن الاثاث وتبحث على مصالحك
فاحنا ساهمنا من خلال هذا العمل في
حل ساهمنا في حل هذه الازمه كذلك كسبنا
خبره انقذنا اطاراتنا الناس كانوا يتخطفون
كانوا يقتلون ولا يدري من قتل لا تدري من
اختطفوا من قتل فاذا احنا درنا السياج على
مناضلين وعلى اطاراتنا حافظنا على بنيتنا
اعطينا فرصه لانفسنا المستقبل
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه ولكن حققنا خسائر
وبعضها استراتيجي من بينها بطبيعه الحال
وهو ان شعبيه تتراجعت لان احنا وجبه
التحرير والتجمع الوطني الديمقراطي كنا في
الحكومه ولكن لما جيد الانتخابات هم
ينقضوا انفسهم بالتزوير ونحن في
مبادره ميثاق الاصلاح السياسي وحتى يكون
حوار بيننا وبين السلطه كنا قد خرج من
الحكومه لما تكلمت
كيف تريد نحن نجلس مع المعارضه انتم مفروض
راكم معانا في الحكومه
انا مجتمع معك
احنا كنا واياكم في الحكومه احنا وجب
التحرير
والتجمع الوطني
واحد يكون في الحكومه يؤخذ من شعبيته
ولكن لما نذهب بالانتخابات
وتنقدكم بالتصوير ونحن ندفع الثمن
يقول لك
لا نقبل التزوير ولكن هذه هذا هذه قسمه
المفروض لا يكون التصوير اذا ندفع الثمن
يعني يعني يكون
مغرم المشاركه بالحكومه يعني لو ندخل في
المبادرات وفي الاصلاحات لا تكفي هذه
الحصه يعني
من شوف احنا بعدين
لما يعني
احنا دخلنا فيه سياق جديد يعني
تجهنا الى رؤيه جديده الى طريق ثالث مش
موجود في الحركات الساميه ماذا تريد
الحكومه منكم يعني لماذا تريد مشاركتكم في
الحكومه سمعت ان هناك حرس حتى حاليا انا
مشاركه
في عروض في الاخيره بعد الانتخابات شرعيه
الاخيره عرض علينا ان يكون عندنا اربعه او
خمسه وزراء يعني واحنا رفضنا يعني لماذا
رفضناه رفضنا لانه كان هناك رفض بان نكون
شركاء في البرنامج وفي رؤيتنا للدوله انت
اذا يعني اذا تكون انت في الحكومه يجب
يعني ان تكون عندك برنامج يكون عندك رؤيه
نحن لا نريد ان نرجع الى عهد بوتفليقه قال
الناس يقول لك انا مع برنامج السيد الرئيس
ولا احد يعرف ما هو برنامج سيد الرئيس اذا
تكون في اتحاد تكون حقيقي على اسس سياسيه
شرعيه
على كل حال لما نكون نحن في الحكومه
سيستفيدون او سيستفيدون في الصوره
الخارجيه سيعطون الانطباع للخارج بان احنا
متحكمين في الوضع
والحزب الاساسي في البلاد معنا كذلك على
مستوى الداخل يعني يستفيدون من حادث
الاستقرار التي تتحقق لهم وكذلك يستفيدون
من انهم لا يسمحون لنا بفضاء
شعبيه لان ازمه لان ازمه الانظمه السياسيه
في العالم العربي انها تضطر اما الانقلاب
او التزوير اي نظام سياسي يجري انقلاب
سيبقى ناقص الشرعيه او معدوم الشرعيه
ويبقى يدفع اثمان كبيره اي نظام سياسي زور
الانتخابات سيبقى منقوص الشرعيه وستبقى
عنده عقده ولا يستطيع ان يكون مرتاح فلذلك
امل الانظمه العربيه ان يصلوا الى
ديمقراطيه امنه يعني شارك الاسلاميه في
الانتخابات ولا ينجحون لا ينجحون
ديمقراطيا بالطبع لما انت لا تكون في
الحكومه
ولكن لا يجب ان يسقطوا تحت ثمانيه في
المئه تحت عشره في المئه يعني يجب ان
يبقوا موجودين يعني
كملمح في الساحه السياسيه ولكن لا يمكن ان
يقوده يعني وهذه بالطبع هذه الكلمه انا
قلت المصريين يعني من قبل قلت لهم بانهم
لن يسمحون لكم بتجاوز 30% فاذا به اشطر
لما التقت بمصر
قالت له نفس الكلام قالت له اذا تقبلوا في
المئه يمكن يسمح لكم ان تمر دكتور عبد
الرزاق رئيس حركه المجتمع السلم الجزائريه
شكرا جزيلا لك حوار شيخ حول الجزائر هذا
ياخذنا
للحلقه الثانيه والحديث حول الخيارات حول
الحاله اليوم الحاله السياسيه الفكريه
بشكل عام في العالم العربي حول تخلفنا
الحضاري بشكل عام وانت تاسس اسست منتدى
بارز لهذا المجال وحول خيارات الاسلاميين
على وجه التحديد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
ايضا التي تعاني المعاناه الاكبر اليوم في
القلب شكرا جزيلا لك ولقائنا في الحلقه
القادمه ان شاء الله شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الك رام نلقاكم ان شاء الله في الاسبوع
المقبل مع الدكتور عبد الرزاق مقري دمتم
بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]